you
okay let's give computer impossible a
try here I'm playing a 10-2 game and
let's see what it throws at us okay so
let's stop five right away to d4 first
and I've had to do this before and it's
going to play Bishop to f5 well my plan
is going to be to do this first control
efore and then chase that bishop away
at age 4 just so I could get a foreign
and my knight I'll have to I'll come
back into play but I want to get this in
I want to build this Center and I might
already want to consider mmm closing it
up well not just yet I think it's
important I get my night back here at
this last move it's not just hitting
here but there's some tricks with Knight
takes pawn Sal
he did what he needed to do and that is
kick the bishop off of that e4 square
the bishop might return here okay I'm
very tempted to play here I think that
this is best probably a good decision in
fact against computer if I don't play
that right away I think Bishop here and
then the night could be landing in to d4
so I want to avoid that so the phase one
kind of hap-happy already against the
computer having a close center so I need
to anticipate f5 I'm thinking about h3
and g4 hmm I wonder if on h3 the knight
would play to h5 no I'll do it
I think it's useful just to stop Bishop
in maybe two okay now on g4 I really
want to play g4 right now but I'm
wondering about h5 maybe I should get
some more development in candidate moves
include Bishop g4 Bishop to e3
but I wanted a clean side castle
I mean if I'm playing g4 I'm pretty much
saying I'm gonna Castle queenside I
might want to remain a bit flexible mmm
if I don't play g4 now I think 9 h5 into
here is a bit of a pain so let me let me
get this in I think we could see h5
maybe no ok so now I'm thinking more
about Bishop e3 or maybe first Bishop
here provoking this and only then maybe
dropping back although wait a moment if
I play Bishop g5 and h5 happens mmm
how do i I think I have to give up my
post on g4 so this is maybe a reason not
to play Bishop g5 Bishop e3 then
would there ever be any sacrifices here
maybe I don't think it could ever be
enough though I need more development
that's for sure let's get a bishop out
I'm not sure where my dark square bishop
belongs okay they're still going with
age five and I don't know that I want to
push
if I push black is eventually going to
have this f6 or f5 advance and then play
along the F file hmm maybe I shouldn't
have gone with this it moves I'm
thinking about night h2
night each two and then Bishop e2 would
be threatening to take here I could
force black to capture like this that
would be great
well I don't know about great but I'm
gonna try and hold my post there on g4
night h2 Bishop e2 I'm expecting some
opening up with this Oh actually c5 I
really like seeing that because it's
more closed okay let's see Bishop to e2
force this capture or force this pond to
do something else I can't be bad
cannon development with the threat hmm
too
computer nests pinning my night
take Z pours on board uh King f1 it's a
little scary town they takes pawn Knight
takes f5 maybe blasting stuff open
because I want to keep this Queen here
my first reaction was Queen d2 but I
want to still keep pressure here I want
to influence this tension I want to
resolve this tension here but am i maybe
going a bit out of my way to do that
Queen d2 Queen d2 queenside castle I
think we can expect soon a 6 b5 or maybe
b5 right away some cases maybe my king
is a better over here that's what I'm
gonna shoot for a king f1 don't want a
castle I want to keep my rook here in
case there's a capture I get an open H
file I doubt that will happen whoo
oh here's another thing I can't even
take here that was silly can't take here
cuz Bishop takes h3 however after King
g2 its back on I would be threatening it
at that point I wonder if I should stop
b5 by playing a 4 a 4 queen bee 4 though
hmm
bishop here would be another way to stop
b5 b5 I could take huh this might be a
move kind of like that instead of giving
up the be 4 square as a whole right away
I'm pretty sure on a for the Queen's
gonna play here I need to make a move
let's try this one stopping b5 is the
main and horse so I thought oh man
really you're really going to do that to
me
Knight takes pawn Queen b6 and then I
have to move back here and this pawn is
picked right up
oh man not liking that that's not cool
at all stay focused though hanging on
and there's got to be something Knight
takes
Queen b6 Knight c3 Queen takes b2 rook
be one Queen a3 Brooke b3 I'm gonna try
this I'll take them suits computer has
to say after this game the stock fish
computer so I'm gonna kick you around a
little bit Queenie get out of my house
let's get another one in there go away
I've got no business being here
okay I feel like I can win up on here no
I still can't I have to do this King G
to move let's get this in here I need to
get this H rook working and maybe I
could abandon this idea of capturing
there maybe I complete my development in
here no yeah that's okay Queen here get
my other rook working I have enough
defense here okay I feel like there's a
little bit of success right there let's
let's get on the only open file that
can't be bad mass exchanges oh okay I'd
like a queen trade maybe that's a way I
could neutralize this pressure here
let's trade a bunch get the rooks off
this space advantage will still be
something in an endgame Queen b3
uh-uh yeah Queen trade you know not so
fast
this is the computer okay I think I want
a little bit of a role reversal here f3
to secure g4
maybe Bishop here and then a three
actually yeah
Bishop d1 now I need more support for
this let's do this missing anything I
don't think so
how's this naked active not seeing it ah
I love seeing that move okay my plan is
to do this not only well yeah I'm doing
this because I want to play 8o let's do
this Knight takes yeah I want to keep
control I don't want to allow this night
to be able to move so quickly because
that frees up this advance okay this was
my idea
a3 offer Queen exchange and then welcome
light square Bishop exchange getting rid
of my bad bishop
Oh another way to do is just night be
one because on a three there's Queen a
five she gets to run away I think I want
a force
yeah I want to force
Queen takes Queen
is there more fish
this I really don't have the time to
calculate it so let's run with this and
then here is this too far-fetched to
capture like this f5 is happening soon
I'll take like this and hold my ground
I'm expecting f5 yes ok take once and
then that's it or I might want to be a
bug actually what about g5 that's super
cramping isn't it although he might be a
bit overextended and picked up somehow I
don't see how you do that though
that takes a long time to do that okay I
don't have any time uh g5 I would really
like to play g5 I'm gonna shoot for it
he had keep the knight out of f6 I feel
like that's the right move okay let's
let's get on with this plan here get rid
of my LightSquared Bishop yeah they're
shuffling I love seeing that keep
shuffling I think that was the correct
move the bishops something like this and
am I trying to say
hm
yes
let's do this not sure what it's really
doing the night's gonna move he's going
there I want to trade that night off
I have to give up my dark-squared bishop
I'm gonna trade nights okay what's the
big trick with this I'm gonna I'm gonna
pick that pawn up on a house this night
getting doing anything kind of sentences
that how does he get doing anything I
feel like I should be winning am I not
just picking up this pawn like okay this
is looking pretty good tonight is a dead
piece but oh he's not dead he could come
over here
like I have this
under control get out of there Bishop
their knight is a dead piece my bishop
is not too good
need a bank sometime Heather Knight is
dead okay I get to rescue oh let's be
careful here
and I don't want to allow their night to
get there I don't know how to make
progress
okay this night could do something else
let's go where exactly here get rid of
that Bishop throne a check just to bang
sometime maybe I'm gonna put pressure on
this pawn mm-hmm okay let's put my
bishop my knight here and then give a
check maybe there's Knight checks here
too let's not forget about that
wanna trade Knights how could I force a
knight trade how could I take this pawn
I don't have time to really think too
much here um my knight in the corner I'm
not so sure about that
let's try to come over here I guess
No I feel like it might be repetition
soon and I don't want to move my night I
don't want to give this square up what
did I do to my night let's okay I have a
plan my night is defending my pond I
have a plan now okay it's starting to
become a bit more clear to me I come
over in this direction my king is making
progress I'm gonna scoop up that a pond
ah this is clean I think let me keep
entering I'll just go right here and
trade nights do you have to go in
tonight trade I think they do like I
think I have it Knight Bishop takes pawn
is my only fear No let's just go here
for a moment um how do I do it hmm
oh I'm gonna go in a different approach
now I think it's probably an easier way
but I'm gonna come over here I have all
day and I want to try something
aha okay my plan is gonna be to force
that pond to move with my knight I want
to keep my king over here defend my pond
and I just want to attack that pond
how do I attack that pond Knight here to
here mm-hmm
she's kind of
short on squares here to heat if I go
here the bishop will trap my knight with
Bishop here I'm glad I didn't do that
Eubanks sometime I could try Knight here
actually okay I like seeing that
Muhammad a win now I think let's come
back here if I had time to think about
this I know I'd be able to come up with
a winning plan the only question is can
I do it in this situation here hmm this
isn't really working so well either the
bishop will be there to defend a knight
here to here the bishop is going to
attack my pawn
I don't like this approach either
let me try one other thing gotta watch
out for the 50 moves I'm gonna sneak
around like this maybe maybe this is a
good approach maybe
as soon as I go here that pond is gonna
be picked up I don't want to allow that
okay I'm gonna try something different
I managed I think okay okay I could
force zooks pong I see it I'm gonna go
with the e5 break final final answer
hopefully it's not going to be the 50
move rule I'm gonna get my king on f3
get my king on f3 and then get my knight
on d3 here here and then push no I could
even do King f4 oh I don't even have to
give up a pawn
let's do this that's the break and now I
have this pawn defended now it's a
different story now I'm going to do that
he's a passed pawn change roles here
change the guard have my knight defend
the pawn and come right back over
slow and steady I have plenty of time
now there we go got him on the ropes and
I'm banking some time which is nice
scoop that pawn up I think we're gonna
see we're gonna see this is this is the
plan I'm going to put my king here
and get my night right here on b5 hmm
that's so easily done huh
what in the world
okay this isn't still is not working
what was the trick should I have just
captured that pond maybe second-guessing
myself that Bishop is so good isn't he
oh I see I see a different idea I'm
gonna put my knight on f4 sorry this is
taking so long
computers out for me a draw get out of
here absolutely not why didn't I think
about putting my knight on that form
whatever my knight leaves there just
she's always gonna he's a the bishop
pressure here okay
being here oh I know how to win this I
know how to won that when the King and
pawn endgame yay finally I feel a
hundred percent confident I'm gonna get
this now what after all that back and
forth my goodness finally this is the
homestretch it's been a long while since
I beat this bugger here it's going down
going down there we go
how to win with the bishop and Knight
checkmate no this is kind of long enough
we don't need any more sophistication
that was way too much sophistication
let's just take this guy keep it simple
watch out for stalemate stalemate so
loud you got one move that's good enough
I write the homestretch stalemate get a
Queenie it'll play on
to checkmate
and I'll stalemates aloud and we'll just
promote and do the little stepladder
finish them off here now stalemate no
stalemate that's good and we're almost
there
we'll see with the stock fish computer
has to say right here and then mate
finally finally okay let's give me a
moment here that was a marathon a lot of
shuffling back and forth I realized but
let me go into analysis mode and we'll
see how we could have improved for sure
okay let's see what the computer has to
say here I'll let you know where there's
any fluctuations I didn't always know
about this particular move I had to find
some something to do against this Bishop
f5 move I've I've played this so many
times against computer and I was just
like how do you ever do anything because
there's always like this and then a
knight move and then that one trade or
Bishop on e4 it's a bit of a bug tonight
h4 move is an interesting way to finally
build that trio of pawns in the center
you're gonna waste some time but mmm may
very well be worth it might be time well
spent to get that Center is eventually
translated into a space advantage which
is nice against computer computer does
not like our stock fish does not like
knight c6 Knight c6 it likes capturing
so there's actually a shift with that
move gives about a point seven advantage
here for white let's see if there were
any I don't think any tactics were
missed because computers gonna pounce on
any tactics that might have been a one
big shift right there to develop the
knight to c6 and I'm a mad I imagine
that when c5 was played it didn't stock
fish isn't gonna like that move at this
point it's recommending h6 interesting
after h5
not too much of a shift it's about even
right here and it still says it's even
after c5 so I'm a bit mistaken there
where could we have done different I
played King f1 here
computers recommended I Castle it's fine
with King f1 that's okay with that move
it does not like b5 aha
it does not like b5 interesting I didn't
see that it would get the pawn back so
we went for this variation essentially
exchanging be pawns and it wants me to
play g5 here but nothing's wrong with
kingi - and I really had to change my
frame of mind around here instead of
focusing on the Kings side I saw an
opportunity to just swap major pieces
and this this base advantage is still
going to be quite telling in an end game
usually it's more of a middle game issue
or not an issue about a middle game
Trump but it could be still quite good
in an ending it's calling out for g5 oh
my the point I want to look at is my
decision to play g5 it's still it's been
giving me a slight advantage all the way
through a slight advantage or even at
times doesn't like that Knight move
what's better than that oh it likes 9 c8
I guess getting in here to taxi for
interesting but instead Knight there and
now it has me out about upon and a half
advantage oh that's pretty significant
and it doesn't want it doesn't like
Knight b1 it likes capturing here better
it was to take take and then Knight a4
and on 85 what do we do Knight b6
yeah I guess so I didn't I was kind of
steering clear or something like that
allowing a two-to-one majority look at
how far away my king is from that but
the computer won't have any problem
knowing that they can stop these guys
here but I went I wanted to keep their
structure as is and I saw a way to now
get this LightSquared Bishop exchange in
and yes this I'm happy to see that this
was a yeah this is the move that it
likes here what would happen if I took I
lose something yeah this is so important
notice how this really kills the night
like this one for sure directly but look
at this guy I forget what game it was
Carlsen in his recent world blitz
championship or something he really
squeezed one opponent and it had to do
with the position of his pawns and the
opponent's Knight wasn't really able to
ever get active notice with this pawn
here and this guy here how does this guy
get active it's quite difficult like
there's no way to get active over here
you go here you're boxed out and you
can't go here you can't go here there's
no forward movements and if you go here
you could go here but there's nothing to
go you can't go anywhere at that point
the only the only Avenue into activity
is by way of b6 but if you cannot make
use of that square it's a pretty much a
dead piece and this knight struggles as
well and the game he ended up going over
here and we had the bishop for Knight
exchange but
okay cool like g5 it's only saying about
a point for advantage now it was giving
up on and-a-half advantage with me
capturing on b4 in that exchange
allowing the two-to-one majority but
just has me as a slight advantage and I
think Knight f4 yeah now it's back up to
a pond and a half so that was a that was
a blunder by the computer and that
should have been let's see what the
cleanest approach was from here now it's
climbing has it at plus two this was a
hundred and sixty nine move game I'm not
gonna be going through every little
detail because there was a lot of back
and forth but uh was that was the
cleanest approach okay yeah it was this
e5 break much earlier so it took forever
for me to realize that maybe I needed to
do that as soon as the e5 break got in
and I was even shuffling after I got my
pawn up there to e6 this guy up here
with that connected past pawn this is
all winning and you know finally got
that knife for a bishop exchange what's
that what's the break here it likes king
b6 King a5 what's King a5 though
I think I need that sometimes sometimes
it could be difficult for even the
computer to figure out certain endings
the correct plan but yeah in the end it
turns out to be that e5 break and it
wants to take yeah I guess so and then
maybe get the knight here
I ended up pushing I guess it might have
been more well it like c6 as well I
guess both they're good but what would
be the follow-up after takes King takes
oh yeah that was foolish
clears day right here you take here here
there's no worry of this pawn falling
and he drops that was stupid I should
have considered it more I knew that this
was a huge trump to have such a
connected past pawn so deep but uh
anyhow as soon as the knight and bishops
were exchanged that's the only point I
felt I knew exactly what I wanted to do
was gonna be a one King and pawn ending
finally it's been for forever since I
beat the computer but anyhow as usual I
hope you got something out this video
and it feel free to leave any comments
in the comment section below that's all
for now
take care
you